ne m'en voulez pas d'avoir osé parler de
ce thème c'est quelque chose qui me
passionne en ce moment alors peut-être
devrais-je ne pas parler de toutes mes
passions sur cette chaîne youtube mais
ça me démange peux pas m'en empêcher
on va parler aujourd'hui ça passe
peut-être mieux quand je montre une
image plutôt que veut dire le mot
attendait avec vos petites a priori la
halle et on est sans voix ailleurs les a
priori les amis aujourd'hui je me suis
rappelé que quand j'étais petit j'ai
apprécié les dominos et j'ai pas pu
enfin est-ce que je rattrape des crises
qui se sont passés il ya 15 ans dans ma
vie oui en 2001 2002 2004 et 2005 sur
tf1
qu'est ce qui a fait une audience de
plusieurs millions de téléspectateurs
[Musique]
domino day c'est quoi les plus jeunes
d'entre vous se souviendront pas mais
les gens qui ont mon âge vous qui sont
plus vieux vous vous souviendrez domino
day les amis c'était une émission
annuelle dans laquelle il y avait des
parcours de dominos gigantesque avec
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
dominos et c'était plusieurs centaines
de bénévoles qui préparait le parcours
pendant deux à trois mois avant
l'émission et c'est fou de dépenser
autant d'énergie dans la confection de
parcours de dominos pourquoi ça s'est
perdu
c'est génial je vais pas faire les mecs
je suis pas un méga fan de dominos j'ai
pas des t-shirts domino et je fais pas
des dominos une fois par semaine mais je
trouve que c'est le truc le plus
satisfaisant du monde
vous avez des problèmes dans la vie
regarder des vidéos de dominos c'est la
dernière strate si après ça vous n'êtes
toujours pas convaincu je ne pourrai
plus rien faire passer à une autre vidéo
mais c'est dommage parce qu'on va en
faire ici tous ensemble juste après au
delà la ronde à tous celui temps ça fait
plaisir
bref c'est un peu comme les vidéos qu'on
a fait ou je tentais déstructurant
ballon gonflable c'est un truc qui à
notre échelle individuelle de gens qu'on
patron est en plein dedans et qui
découvrent n'est pas très impressionnant
mais quand tu regardes ce que les
champions du monde de dominos ou de
structures de ballons font ça rentre
dans la catégorie de ces deux là en fait
carrément tellement c'est incroyable
d'ailleurs après ma vidéo sur les
ballons vous avez été plein m'envoyer
des images de structures incroyable fait
en ballon et makes it raw impressions et
ben les dominos c'est la même chose donc
je propose qu'on regarde quelques vidéos
de gens très fort et qu'ensuite on s'y
colle
alors sur youtube le roi du domino games
et domino king blind lui fait pas des
parcours à sensations il fait ce qu'on
appelle du dessin je sais pas comment on
appelle ça ok je viens trouver un terme
qui ne définit pour le non pas du tout
ce qui fait voilà par exemple il a fait
un petit speech doivent regarder c'est
impressionnant voilà il ya un truc très
flou et en fait ça fait tomber les
couleurs au bon endroit et du coup le
dessin apparaît c'est fou les faits il
est génial je pouvais garder ça pour en
fait le moment où les dominos tombent et
où le dessin apparaît bien c'est
tellement satisfaisant
c'est un truc c'est incroyable effet que
ça fait je suis vraiment en train
d'essayer de ramener le domino à la mode
c'est un grand pas mine mais j'ai envie
aux noms
merveilleux incroyable la taille au nom
et ça repart dans l'autre sens il a
juste inverser le sens de la vidéo
peut-être ne suis-je pas très objectif
finalement ok vous n'êtes pas convaincu
ben maintenant on va regarder des
parcours mais qd c'est marrant parce que
cette vidéo aurait gelé vue il ya bac
juste après qu'elle soit sortie je crois
elle est devenue un peu virale oui une
vidéo de dominos qui devient virale
grave et ce quelqu'un qui a des packs de
dominos les mêmes que j'ai commandé la
et à utiliser mais par contre cette
personne a un truc que je n'ai pas c'est
le talent pour faire des parcours de
deux mines regardez combien de boîtes de
dominos et à regarder tous les
accessoires que ya ça commence déjà par
une toupie c'est une toupie qui
déclenche le premier domino le level il
est très haut là c'est une guillotine
qui envoie une boule sur des dominos et
une tyrolienne qui déclenche une autre
série torino hélas est partie elle est
ratée parce que les boules ne sont pas
attraper par les dinosaures et j'ai vu
dans les commentaires des gens aiment
vraiment très déçu premier degré que ça
ait raté genre vraiment les gens étaient
en colère du genre allez vraiment
premier degré c'est incroyable je sais
que là si d'un coup on prenait du recul
sur la vidéo vous vous dites mais qu'est
ce qui se passe sur la chaîne
c'est normal mais on assume on est plus
apprécié ce qui se passe si on est
vraiment bien les loopings
extraordinaire ça va décoller
non c'est fou j'espère que vous êtes un
peu sensible et j'ai découvert un
truc qui est trop drôle mais c'est les
dominos géants mais c'est pas genre
juste départ contre dominos géants ça
commence tout petit et ça finit immense
et il a peur du bruit que fait le
dernier la prochaine mais j'ai eu un fou
rire quand je joue je suis honnête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la prochaine étape mec c'est
le dernier domino c'est un immeuble ça
me fut mais bon on a regardé vous êtes
un peu au courant de ce qui se passe
dans le domino game de ce que c'est de
ce qu'il est possible de faire il est
maintenant temps de passer en mode
activités manuelles et vous savez que je
suis une sacrée merde
bon alors évidemment j'ai dit à trier un
peu les boîtes ici on a plein de dominos
on va faire des jeux pour l'enfant c'est
pas agréable mais je vous jure qu un
prix ça va l'être j'ai acheté des
parcours comme ça et du jardin et des
accessoires voiliers qui sont un peu qui
change un peu juste du trait domino
classique comme on voit mais on va
commencer par un trait dominant
classique j'ai 4 ans et demi
c'est effrayant hockey des nominés temps
de faire ensemble notre premier rail de
dominos
pas d'accessoires juste nous nos mains
et les dominos et la satisfaction à la
clé évidemment qui sera notre récompense
c'est quelqu'un de me voir il basait sur
burnout mais complet alors que non
j'aime bien ce que vous êtes prêts court
mais intense comme la première fois
assez frustrant j'ai envie qu'ils se
remettent instantanément droits et de
leur faire c'est chiant la base de sa
attendait mais est ce que je serais pas
en train d'amorcer une transition pour
la suite de ma vidéo la sésamie on a
plus 8 ans et comme on n'a plus huit ans
en gagne sa vie et quand on gagne sa vie
on achète ce site
[Musique]
la jalousie est un sentiment normal
face à ce que vous êtes en train de
boire souci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non mais quel modèle à la bible
mais rangé sa fait du bruit en forme et
la fin de la ferme à la pitié ok c'est
bien sûr un terme à travailler ok
maintenant fou relier les lignes ter
pitié pas de fausse manip je vous
impressionner des premiers trucs qu'on
fait ah oui au fait c'est pas ce monde
sauf si certains avaient des doutes et
qui se disait braille date à toucher une
somme folle
finalement non ouais mais non on sait
plus que là bas
[Musique]
belle réussite
c'est trop bien en train de devenir fou
ok là laissez moi vous présenter tout ce
que j'ai dans mon garage comme un
accessoire un bon on met des dominos
dessus et ça crée un peu de verticalité
dans une dimension qui de base est très
horizontale
parce que j'utilise des termes beaucoup
trop sérieux pour ce sujet non c'est
sérieux ce qui se passe à l'étude verges
il faut qu'un dominos tombent sur ceux
ci et ensuite ça fait partie rugby d'ici
qui va jusqu'en bas et qui déclencha un
autre demi noël arrivait vraiment
impressionnant n'est-ce pas ça c'est des
rails auquel on va accrocher les dominos
qui font partie d'un parcours bien
pressés à l'issue duquel se trouve un
looping
mais j'adore voici grosso modo comme
assembler parcours il y aura deux
loopings deux tours verte et le petit
bridge qui est là et ça va être de la
balle mais avant tout la difficulté va
être dévalué où va la voiture vraiment
pas où aller taper les chaînes canal qui
va là qui va là qu'on voit ça là qui
continue tu vas au c'est incroyable oh
ça y est ça y est je m'y colle je vous
raconte le parcours dès qu'il est prêt
au charbon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on arrive bientôt au bout la lâcher que
vous avez hâte plus que jamais de voir
si ça va marcher que vous espérez
secrètement que ça marche pas pour voir
la réaction de mecs dépité parce que
vous vous nourrissez mes frustrations et
de mes peurs et de ma colère de
bienvenue bon franchement on a un beau
parcours je suis assez fier là il me
reste juste à placer les dominos sur les
escaliers et ensuite à amorcer les trucs
qui lance les voitures ça threat la
partie technique parce que ces trucs là
ça a l'air d'être des vrais fourberie on
va déjà faire ce truc là bas est à fort
boyard dans les épreuves d'agilité de
merde vous savez ça c'est
tellement dangereux si j'en fais tomber
ça va tout gâcher ok ça s'est fait plus
qu à amorcer des machines de la mort à
la porte
mais l'annoncé pas celui-là il a amorcé
y'a plus qu'à mettre les voitures en
place mais avant ça j'aimerais vous dire
qu'à une zone à risque
il ya une erreur dans le parcours ya une
erreur de conception d'ingénierie et
c'est ma photo kg j'accepte les
responsabilités qui vont avec c'est
qu'en fait la voiture elle doit passer
au dessus de ça pour aller shoot est là
mais elle va sûrement shooter un domino
cas là donc le pire scénario sur aix
domino là il shoote celui là qui joue
dessus du lac du coup le parcours
continue ici alors qu'il n'est pas passé
par là comme prévu donc voilà j'espère
que ça va marcher en fait je place la
belge a fait oublier la vie oh je
stresse mec les voitures j'ai failli
oublier les voitures
ok tout est bien en place je vais
procéder au déclenchement je ne sais pas
si je filme bien géré de caméras
peut-être c'est la merde mais en tout
cas ce qu'on vit c'est un grand nombre
c'est mon premier vrai parcours de
dominos qui sera peut-être le dernier
selon l'issue j'ai tout donné j'ai tout
calculer alors je vais pas désamorcé un
potentiel échec parce qu'il aura pas
d'échec c'est parti
[Musique]
on
des jaloux mon petit pote tu es jaloux
tous un petit rat jeu va oui c'était
court mais intense comme toutes les fois
qu'ils ont suivi la première les amis
c'est la fin de cette vidéo je suis
heureux moi j'ai fait un parcours de
dominos le même que les enfants de 8 ans
font après avoir reçu ces cadeaux la
noël quelle chance je suis trop content
[Musique]